a continuación cada gráfica de puntos
representa un conjunto diferente de
datos lo podemos ver aquí y dice ordena
las gráficas de puntos de la que tenga
la mayor desviación estándar en la parte
superior a la que tenga menor desviación
estándar en la parte inferior pausa el
vídeo y face y puedes resolverlo o sí
por lo menos puedes clasificar estas
gráficas desde la que tiene la mayor
desviación estándar hasta la que tiene
la menor desviación estándar bien vamos
a trabajar juntos estoy haciendo esto en
khan academy donde puedo mover estas
gráficas para ordenarlas recordemos que
es la desviación estándar y como la
podemos percibir podemos ver la
desviación estándar como la medida de la
distancia típica de cada uno de estos
puntos a la media por lo tanto la mayor
desviación estándar la que queremos
poner en la parte superior será aquella
en donde típicamente los datos estén más
alejados de la media
mientras que la menor desviación
estándar será aquella en donde en
promedio los puntos estén más cercanos a
la media ahora bien en todos estos
ejemplos parece que la media está justo
en el centro justo a la mitad entre 50 y
100 es decir alrededor del 75 así que en
realidad se trata de ver qué tan
separados o dispersos están los puntos
de ese valor de la media si observamos
la primera tiene dos puntos uno a la
derecha y otro a la izquierda que están
muy lejos después siguen estos dos
puntos que están un poco más cerca y por
último estos dos puntos que están mucho
más cerca por dentro esta otra de acá
para ir de edad de arriba a la de abajo
lo que pasó fue que tomamos este punto y
lo alejamos la media también tomamos
este otro punto y lo alejamos de la
media por lo tanto esta segunda gráfica
tiene una desviación estándar mayor que
la primera por lo tanto la subida de
esta manera
y quiero ser muy claro hay que mantener
un seguimiento de cuál es la diferencia
entre estas dos gráficas aquí tenemos
este punto y este otro que estaban más
cercanos a la media y si los alejamos
entonces haremos que nuestra distancia
típica entre la media y este punto
aumente que es justo lo que pasa acá
arriba ahora que podemos decir de la
tercera bueno la diferencia entre la
segunda gráfica y la tercera es que
estamos tomando este punto y este punto
y los acercamos a la media eso hace que
nuestra distancia típica a la media
disminuya por lo tanto esta tercera
gráfica tendrá una menor detención
estándar de la que tenemos arriba la
mayor bien hagamos otro ejemplo aquí
tenemos la misma idea ordena las
gráficas de puntos de la que tenga la
mayor desviación estándar en la parte
superior a la que tenga la menor
desviación estándar en la parte inferior
pausa el vídeo e intenta acomodar las
este vídeo es muy interesante porque
todas las gráficas tienen distintas
medias a simple vista la primera gráfica
tiene una
por aquí donde se encuentra el tercer
punto la media de la segunda gráfica
está por acá alrededor de 10 y la media
de la tercera está por acá que parece
ser la misma media que la primera
gráfica pausa el vídeo como las ordenar
y as a simple vista en esta gráfica de
medio
la distancia típica entre los puntos y
la media parece ser la mayor si la media
hasta aquí tienes estos dos puntos que
están muy lejos de la media e incluso
estos otros dos puntos están al menos
tan distantes como cualquier otro punto
de las otras gráficas por lo tanto
podemos decir que en esta gráfica
tenemos la mayor desviación estándar
ahora si comparamos estas otras dos y
pensamos en cómo obtener sus diferencias
podemos ver que si tomamos este punto y
lo movemos hacia la media y de igual
manera para este otro punto lo movemos
hacia la media
entonces obtendríamos esta tercer
gráfica en esta tercera situación
tenemos la menor cantidad de puntos
ubicados lejos de la media para acción
con las de arriba por
y este es el orden adecuado la primera
gráfica tiene la mayor desviación
estándar y la tercera gráfica tiene la
menor eso es todo por este vídeo nos
vemos en el siguiente